hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lynn Doris Abby rapid challenge at the
finals this is the second match and this
is Game four so after winning Game one
after double winning Game one in Game
two and three would run anywhere they
were pretty solid draw so I decided not
to show those games and now Hikaru is in
a must-win situation with the black
pieces if he wants to try and force
Armageddon was trying to force game five
and win this entire match without
actually going into the third day of the
matches so dubov goes for d4 and the
Nakamura now sir about that goes for f5
he goes for the Dutch defense so this is
what a Nakamura chooses for a must-win
situation we have g3 by dubov and Knight
to f6 with Bishop the g-tube in catering
the bishop and g6 going for the
Leningrad the Dutch formation and nights
the d2 now preparing to bust open the
position with E for so first nice to see
six putting pressure on d4 and Knight G
to f3 defending the pawn here and Bishop
to g7 and now there is one game where c3
was played and also again where c4
displayed but castles is a new move
sorry castles by white is a new move and
it is as a move six that we have a
completely new game Nakamura also
castles in the now we have rook to e1
again preparing e4 and the Nakamura
stops that with d5 so c4 and c6 now
creating sort of a sort of a stone wall
structure here we have b3 preparing to
fianchetto the bishop here to counter
black's
dark square bishop and now Knight to e4
with a double attack on the pawn here so
do both defensive Bishop to b2 and now
g5 Nakamura go he's going for g4 to
dislodge this night from f3 we have rook
a to c1 dubov just continues development
and the g4 now attacking the knight here
95 and now Knight captures on e5 we have
D captures on e5 and c6 so strengthening
in the center and the Nakamura does a
story du bois that does have a double e
pawn but it's a very strong a pawn and
really puts pressure on blacks position
here so it's not a liability
and here Nakamura sorry dubov could go
for some like characters captures and f4
now but it's a hard position to evaluate
for example if he captures on f3 ALPA
song and then captures captures and
after Bishop captures it looks a bit
weird you're you weak in your Kings
position and it's it's it is very hard
to evaluate especially for a rapid game
however white should be preferred here
as black will have a lot of problems
developing this light-square bishop due
to the e6 pawn
hence the the plus side of having that
pawn on e5 which is no longer doubled
however instead of knife captures Du
Bois goes for f3 right away and he did
this spend some time calculating this
and what happens here but it's important
know that Queen to b6 check doesn't
really work you don't have something
like king h1 night if to check pics of
the Queen because of c5 and after Knight
captures the pawn bishop d4 just wins
that night here there's no no no defense
against this so instead after f3
nakamura decides for night capture Sundy
- Queen captures and h5 he now wants to
go h4 and try and open up this position
however Google goes f4 closes up the
King side completely and h4 by Nakamura
but now c5 and now it's extremely
difficult to open up the position your
duo will play Bishop to d4 which will
create a very solid center and if any
breakthrough is possible in the future
it will be something like b6 but as the
the King side is pretty much closed you
don't really care about characters
captures this will still be very solid
for white it will be very hard for
Nakamura to break through so King to f7
with some ideas of capturing maybe bring
your rook over to h8 create some threats
on the King side but double just
continues improving the position bursts
from d4 we have looked at a trait and
now came to f2 the king will not also
help out with the defense here and you
also make room for your rook here so if
characters captures happen and maybe you
can bring your rook over to h2 for
example then rook the g1 will be will be
very solid so Bishop to d7 and erectus
3.now add another defender to the
third-ranked keeping an eye on
everything bishop to f/8 and the now
comes wrote the g1 just preparing for
characters captures and let's say rook
to h2 but Bishop to e7 now and Nakamura
also tries to improve his pieces as much
as possible but now King Teti one do
boom now decides to shift the King over
to the Queen side where it is safer so
Queen to C 7 by Nakamura and kink the d1
now by dubov and finally b6 by nakamura
he says okay if you're bringing your
King to the center of the board I'm now
definitely opening up that the center
here and if b4 then a 5 will be very
strong since you will open up the a file
for for the rogue then you can double up
looks on the a file and it will be very
dangerous for white so Queen III by
dubov and now comes Queen to b7 by
nakamura also something to consider is
something like h3 Bishop to h1 + b5 but
this is something that perhaps Leela
would play and it's very hard for for
humans to play chess like this for
example maybe you bring your queen here
quinta a3 then you push a 5 a 4 create a
breakthrough on the Queen side and so on
so Nakamura goes Queen - b7 first would
ideas of Quinta a six maybe then
bringing the Queen over to a 3 and now
rook the c2 by do both we have rook a to
b8 now also possible here is just a
trade everything on c5 oh it's a bishop
characters character screen captures and
then let's say something like this
Bishop here and rook H to be 8 which is
definitely a plus for black as you've
opened up some lines you can play a 5 a
4 next and you if you manage to get your
- up into the game somehow move the
Queen ship the bishop over here black
should have some chances however
Nakamoto goes to rook a to be 8 and now
dubov goes back with the King King to e
1 we have Quinta a6 and now King back to
f2 so Du Bois just took a nice stroll
here with the King and then back as now
nakamura decided to open up the Queen
side and finally h3 by Nakamura with the
ship to f1 by do both and now B captures
on c5 finally opening up we have Bishop
actress and now rook the BFI with a
double attack on the bishop here so
characters and characters and now Queen
back to D - defending that a two point
so you don't have to worry about
anything and it really it really does
seem like Du Bois is not trying to win
this game he's just trying to keep the
position solid as he only needs a draw
to win this match and force a third
match since he is a upper point in the
match so Queen to a three by Nakamura
now maybe you can bring the other bloke
over to the Queen side maybe start
pushing that a pawn and now III and just
very solid opening up the bishop here so
rook to a5 and now Bishop to d3 and now
it's a it's an extremely solid position
for do both very very hard for key card
to bust open the position so he tries
with c5 but now rook G to C one adding
another rook to the C file and now rook
to b8 so Hikaru is trying but Du Bois
just says okay I'm just gonna wait and
see what what your plan is as I'm very
happy with a draw here so look the Beast
6bi Hikaru and now Bishop back to f1 Du
Bois is simply waiting and here Bishop
the c8 now the problem is Du Bois is
only waiting but he's spending a lot of
time on this whole waiting idea Dougal
doesn't usually play chess like this and
I think this is much harder for him than
to actually play for a win he only has
three and a half minutes left on the
clock whereas Hikaru has some six and a
half minutes but here Du Bois finds an
absolute absolutely beautiful move you
could just repeat repeat Bishop e2
Bishop f1 and of course black will not
have anything to do about that
however he for the move of place is just
just spectacular
yeah point is if you play D captures on
e4 then rook to d1 and there is no
defense you're getting made it here
whatever you try you're just gonna get
checkmated there's not nothing for you
to do here it's just silly if you try
something like this the guard your
Bishop it's just a very very quick
checkmating sequence the rope will come
to the edge with check and then work the
h8 this checkmate
so this is what the Du Bois finds and on
the other hand if this pawn captures
that f5 is incredibly strong then the
Queen gets to go to g5 to harass the
King
and then well what it gets at least a
draw but of course can push for more so
Nakamura decides to close it with the d4
and now comes a bishop back to d3
DuBose's
okay now I forced you to play this I'm
gonna capture on f5 next maybe and I
like my position here so Bishop to d7 by
Nakamura and now just look the e1
preparing to open up woody captures an
f5 and now Queen to b4 offering a queen
trade now if this was any other game
where Dubeau didn't need a draw to win
the match he would probably go back with
Queen e2 or queen d1 next play he
captures on f5 and pushed for a win here
however do will be satisfied with a draw
and he trades Queens here so characters
and characters and now he captures on f5
we have eke actress in the rook e - E -
now just adding another defender here
saying I'm very solid here I'm just
gonna repeat moves and win the match
so Bishop to e6 by Nakamura but now rook
eita d2 duo just repeating rook to be
seven and now Bishop to c4 we looked the
c7 by Nakamura and now you can win a
pawn here however dubov says that he can
win the pawn later on and he's very
happy with a draw like I've mentioned so
he just trades here Bishop characters on
e6 rook captures and c2 with rook
captures and King captures on e6 and now
Lugo brings the King into the game
Nakamura does the same and King to b3
now saying that okay I'm just gonna
bring my rook over to e2 and then push
my pawn here and if you want to prevent
this you're gonna have to move the King
and only then will I capture the pawn so
Nakamura decides to block with the rook
so he doesn't have to give up the d4
pawn however do both the genius here
just plays rook to e2 here and now the
problem is yes he carved walks with the
rook but now duo just goes rook to c2
and Hikaru has no moves he if he moves
the King he again loses the pawn so he
repeats rook t6 and the double go to
rock - E - he's very happy with a draw
here and now Nakamura can either grab a
draw by repeating moves or kinked east
sex which Nakamura goes for but in doing
so gives up the d4 pawn so du Bois grabs
it and now rook the c6
King to e3 du Bois just
Pete smooches gonna repeat this sorry
this doesn't really matter so Nakamura
prevents it rook the c3 check King d2
and now rook the f3 with some ideas of
maybe maybe going like this if the rook
attacks rook but again gube of the
genius without any problems figures out
how to force a draw here rook to e3
of course any rook trades are favorable
only for white since white is up a pawn
has a fast epon so look back to f1 but
now duo just repeats rook e1 we have
looked after check rook to e2 but now
nakamura finds rook to g2 of course now
trading is favorable for him as
promotion will be unstoppable
so after Luke - G - we have just kinked
a d1 no the book says I'm just gonna
repeat my moves with the King here so
King to e7
but now King d2 we have King to d7 King
to d1 we have kinked East six but now
pink the d2 and here nakamura does
something something well you should
never do but since he Nakamura is in a
position where he either wins or he
loses and then he can again try tomorrow
so it doesn't really make all that much
difference for him since there's really
no way to push for more than a draw here
however he tries with King to d5 but
King the d5 is actually a losing move so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move for white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on not pushing East six
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show its King to e3 now the
point is black really has no choice he
can either trade here and then like we
said look trades except for this one are
favorable for white or you go back like
say King e6 but now just characters
characters King f2 you're gonna win
another pawn and whatever black plays
you're gonna grab this one now you're up
two points and of course completely
winning so that's the problem however
dubov just went east six he only wants a
draw he doesn't care for a win here and
now Nakamura unless he wants to allow
East 7 and e 8 has to capture this with
check so characters with check King
capture screen captures on e6 and I'll
double just goes came to d3 the materi
is equal and the position is completely
blocked King d5 we have King III now a
sex but King back to d3 king c5 and here
we have King III and after this we had
one more pawn move but then we had just
a few more moves with the king king d5
III c5 d3 and king D 5 and it was in
this position that I don't think the
players agree to I think it was actually
a draw by threefold repetition but still
game 4 ends in a draw and the duel of
wins the match so here now this is the
you might think this is a silly decision
to instantly play e6 your rather than
try to find a winner with King to e3 but
I've seen this happen and many times on
many levels in my own chess club as well
when you only need a draw for for
example for our team to win and you
think you've found a win and then you go
for a win and then you lose and then
your entire team loses for example ok
this is not a team event but still you
know it's a draw and you win the match
so it's always possible that you've
missed something when you find the
winning move so I'm going for the draw
here it was actually be the only choice
Liubov could make sure do Bob wins the
match and this means tomorrow we have a
third match so more chess chess fun and
enjoyment for us so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jeff graves Robert for David Brown
jock of Judah and jörgen killing for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot that really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Isle indoors ABI rapid challenge finals
until it finishes checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day